[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> IF YOU'RE HUNGRY FOR
CHICKEN, THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
BETTER TIME TO COME TO BOK BOK.
GET YOUR CHOICE OF A SIX PIECE
CHICKEN SUPREME SNACK.
OR A TWO PIECE CHICKEN DINNER
FOR 8.99 EACH.
ALL SERVED WITH A FRESH BISCUIT
AND A FLAVORFUL FIXEN.
ALSO, WE'D LIKE TO TAKE A SECOND
TO CLEAR UP A FEW THINGS YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD ABOUT OUR MASCOT, BOK
BOK.
WHO DOES BEAR A SLIGHT
RESEMBLANCE TO THE INTERNET
URBAN LEDGE AND MOMO.
BUT WE PROMISE, BOK BOK IS NOT
MOMO IN A CHICKEN SUIT.
AND SHE'S DEFINITELY NOT
TEMPTING KIDS WITH CHICKEN SO
SHE CAN STEEL THEIR SOULS.
BOK BOK IS ALL ABOUT BRINGING
YOU JUICY CHICKEN SERVED HOT.
AMD SURE, LIKE MOMO, BOK BOK IS
A HUMAN BIRD HYBRID WHO LOVES
THE COMPANY OF CHILDREN.
BUT WHO CARES WHEN THE FOOD IS
THIS GOOD.
>> PLEASE STOP FEEDING MY SON.
>> SO STOP BEING PARANOID AND
BRING THE WHOLE FAMILY DOWN.
>> HEY, WHAT CAN I GET YOU
TODAY?
>> WHAT DO YOU GUYS WANT?
>> CHICKEN.
[ BLEEP ].
>> YEAH, THAT'S PROBABLY MOMO.
>> TAKE YOUR CHILDREN TO BOK
BOK'S.
>> SEE YOU SOON.